[Música]
jornada electoral crucial en Estados
Unidos Este martes es el país vota en
las elecciones de medio término para
renovar la cámara de representantes un
tercio del senado y 36 gobernadores
estatales los comicios determinarán el
resto del mandato de Joe biden
en Egipto concluyó la tercera jornada de
la Copa 27 hoy fue el último día de la
Cumbre de líderes de alto nivel la
justicia climática entre el norte y el
sur global está en el centro del debate
Tenemos reporte desde charmel Shake
Turquía mantiene El veto sobre la
entrada de Suecia y Finlandia a la otan
después de que el presidente Turco se
reuniera hoy con el nuevo Primer
Ministro sueco la extradición de
supuestos miembros del phk es la
principal exigencia de erdoan Tenemos
reporte desde Estambul
buenas tardes y bienvenidos a las
noticias de Franz 24 en español Soy Rosa
Pérez mateu y es para mí un gusto
acompañarles empezamos esta edición en
Estados Unidos porque hoy se desarrolla
una jornada electoral clave que va a
determinar los dos años restantes de
mandato de Joe biden en las elecciones
legislativas de medio término de hoy el
país elige los diputados de la cámara de
representantes y un tercio del senado
así como la mayoría de los gobernadores
ahora recordemos la composición actual
del legislativo por un lado en el senado
hay 50 senadores republicanos y 48
demócratas además de dos independientes
que normalmente votan junto a estos
últimos el partido demócrata que goza de
una frágil mayoría gracias al voto de la
vicepresidentara demócrata kamala Harris
que vale por dos por otro lado en la
cámara de representantes el partido
demócrata cuenta con mayoría por una
diferencia de 8 escaños pero los últimos
sondeos indican que con toda
probabilidad hoy los republicanos van a
ganar la cámara baja por último los 50
estados están gobernados por 22
demócratas y 28 republicanos Hoy está en
el juego 36 gobernaciones y tres
territorios de ultramar
y los resultados finales de estos
comicios podrían tardar horas e incluso
días en llegar debido a que cada estado
tiene una legislación electoral distinta
Andrés triviño nos explica
a la espera de los resultados debido a
que las elecciones en Estados Unidos no
son organizadas por una autoridad
central sino que se rigen por la
legislación de cada estado nos espera un
anuncio general de los resultados una
vez cerrada las urnas cada estado decide
las reglas de juego para que su
ciudadanos ejerzan su derecho al voto
Algunos permiten que las votaciones
inicien semanas antes pero otros no
dejan que esto ocurra sino hasta el
mismo día de las elecciones causando
grandes retrasos en los conteos finales
más de 43 millones de estadounidenses
votaron anticipadamente por correo o en
persona siendo California Texas y
Florida los más anticipados
usualmente los demócratas prefieren
votar por correo mientras que los
republicanos optan por la presencialidad
así los reportes de los resultados se
conocerán en distintos momentos durante
la noche del 8 de noviembre y en los
días posteriores
para las elecciones de medio término de
2018 los resultados parciales que
dejaron como ganador al partido
demócrata se conocieron Un día después
para obtener la victoria se necesita una
mayoría simple el partido que logre
superar 50 votos sobre 100 gana si no se
alcanza este número se debe citar a una
segunda vuelta el próximo 6 de diciembre
estas elecciones renovarán la cámara de
representantes un tercio del senado y 36
gobernaciones y son cruciales para saber
el rumbo que tomará la gestión del
presidente Joe biden hasta el final de
su mandato y la fuerza de Donald Trump
de Cara a su posible candidatura
presidencial para los comicios del 2024
y estas elecciones son la razón por las
que el presidente estadounidense show
biden Todavía no se ha desplazado a
Egipto donde hoy concluyó la tercera
jornada de la Copa 27 y la llamada
cumbre de los líderes con la justicia
climática en el centro del debate los
países pobres y en desarrollo insisten a
los Estados ricos en crear más
mecanismos de solidaridad climática dado
que es el sur global quien sufre las
consecuencias más devastadoras de la
crisis Mientras que el norte es el
principal responsable por otro lado hoy
intervino virtualmente en la Cumbre del
presidente ucraniano bolodimirsele quien
declaró que el planeta ya no soporta un
disparo más
la guerra rusa destruyó 5 millones de
Acres de bosques en Ucrania en menos de
seis meses no todos los países del Mundo
tienen un área de bosques como la
quemada en Ucrania por los bombardeos
la guerra rusa trajo una crisis
alimentaria aguda al mundo que afectó
más a los países que sufren las
manifestaciones existentes del cambio
climático sequías catastróficas e
inundaciones a gran escala
los puntos más relevantes de esta
tercera jornada de la cop 27 con nuestra
enviada especial en charmelec María
Clara calle
después de dos días terminó la Cumbre de
los líderes hoy con uno de los discursos
más esperados el de Pakistán su Primer
Ministro muhammad sharif propuso que se
cree un índice global de riesgos
climáticos para que se priorice la
financiación a los países que corren más
riesgos como el suyo que enfrentó las
peores inundaciones de la época reciente
otra de las evidencias de esta
injusticia climática se vive en las
islas Cook el Primer Ministro Mark Brown
aseguró que el 99% de su territorio está
a nivel del mar por lo que casi todo
podría inundarse si los océanos crecen
por eso le hizo un llamado al grupo del
g20 que produce el 80% de las
contaminaciones a que contribuya más y
parte de este grupo es la Unión Europea
quien también se pronunció hoy Charles
Michel el presidente del Consejo europeo
y Úrsula bunderleyen la presidenta de la
comisión europea hablaron en el mismo
sentido por un lado reiterar que ha
utilizado la energía como un arma y por
otro decir que el bloque de los 27 ha
sido un campeón climático ya que aportó
21.000 millones de euros para la
financiación climática en 2021 Y aunque
Úrsula Wonderland utilizó un discurso
más fuerte al hacer un llamado a los
países del Norte global a que cooperen
al final nunca mencionó los daños y las
pérdidas recordemos que la Unión Europea
se opuso en Glasgow a la creación de un
fondo para este hecho Y por último la
ONU propuso una agenda para la
adaptación con más de 30 planes que
Espera que se cumplan antes del 2030
en otras noticias el presidente Turco
recepta Jeep erdogan mantiene sujeto
sobre el ingreso de Finlandia y Suecia a
la otan después de reunirse hoy en
ankara con el nuevo Primer Ministro de
Suecia ulfristarson recordemos que tanto
helsinki como estocolmon solicitaron
entrar a la alianza atlántica a raíz de
la invasión rusa de Ucrania pero que
todos los miembros de la otan deben
aprobar las solicitudes y una de las
condiciones que impone Turquía Suecia es
la extradición de supuestos miembros del
pkk a territorio Turco nuestro
corresponsal en Estambul Adrián Rocha
nos amplía
Turquía mantiene sujeto a la entrada de
la otan de Suecia a Finlandia así lo ha
explicado esta misma tarde el presidente
Turco reserva y perdón que ha recibido
en ankara al Primer Ministro seco ulf
christens explicado que Turquía
considera que Suecia sobre todo Suecia
pero también Finlandia se han convertido
en Estados en los cuales la democracia
es usada por organizaciones terroristas
para mantener allí sus personas ha dicho
que es algo que se tiene que evitar
crisis en ha dicho que va a seguir todos
los compromisos adquiridos con Turquía
que fueron adquiridos el pasado mes de
junio en Madrid en la Cumbre de la otan
por la que a través de la cual se
certificó la entrada de Finlandia y
Suecia a el proceso para entrar
definitivamente a la ota en este proceso
sin embargo aún no ha terminado Porque
todos los estados miembros de la otan
tienen que ratificar la entrada de un
nuevo país a través de sus parlamentos
faltan dos que voten a favor de la
entrada de Finlandia Suecia la otan son
el de Hungría y el de Turquía Turquía de
hecho sigue con este veto
sobre todo por la razón en que Turquía
quiere que se deporten a supuestos
miembros de organizaciones terroristas
sobre todo el pkk ha considerado
terrorista tanto por Turquía como para
la Unión Europea y la cofradía de efecto
lagunen desde Suecia y Finlandia hacia
Turquía Turquía el mes de junio pasó una
lista de 70 alto en torno a 70 personas
que Turquía quería deportadas Solo han
sido cuatro y los demás de momento no la
han sido nos espera que lo hagan por el
hecho de que es la justicia sueca la que
tiene que decir caso por caso de hecho
nos espera que el veto Turco sea
retirado hasta finales de primavera del
año que viene incluso entrado al verano
Turquía en junio tiene que celebrar unas
elecciones presidenciales cruciales para
el futuro tanto de erdogan como del país
sanatorio
continuamos con información relacionada
con la guerra en Ucrania Porque mientras
se intercambian ataques públicos
Washington y Moscú también se comunican
en privado para reducir el riesgo de la
guerra nuclear la revelaciones del fin
de semana del medio estadounidense de
Wall Street journal sobre una línea
directa entre los dos países fueron
confirmadas el lunes por Jake Sullivan
el principal asesor de seguridad del
presidente estadounidense shoeiden pero
Moscú niega rotundamente la información
más detalles en el siguiente informe
porque a pesar de los enfrentamientos
abiertos sobre Ucrania la casa blanca y
el kremlin están en comunicación el
asesor de seguridad Nacional de Estados
Unidos Jake Sullivan confirmó el lunes
que ha estado en contacto con altos
asesores de Vladimir Putin durante
varios meses las conversaciones privadas
se centraron principalmente en limitar
la escalada de la guerra en Ucrania y
evitar el uso de armas nucleares
nosotros en la administración de vaiden
hemos tenido la oportunidad de
comprometernos altos niveles con los
rusos para comunicarnos para reducir el
riesgo para transmitir la consecuencia
del uso potencial de las armas nucleares
putina insinuado en repetidas ocasiones
que podría recurrir a la fuerza si las
cosas no salen como él quiere en Ucrania
provocando la condena internacional y
una feroz reprimenda por parte de los
funcionarios estadounidenses no está
claro si el presidente ruso ha
participado directamente en las
recientes conversaciones con Washington
el kremlin de entrada ha negado
rotundamente las negociaciones
no tenemos nada que decir sobre esta
publicación los periódicos anglosajones
publican muchas falsedades
durante la Guerra Fría la casa blanca y
el kremlin mantuvieron un canal de
comunicación directa conocido como
hotline para ayudar a reducir la
posibilidad de la guerra nuclear el
barco humanitario Ocean viking con 234
inmigrantes Salvados en el Mediterráneo
central hace 18 días puso Este martes
rumbo hacia Francia tras el rechazo de
las autoridades italianas de garantizar
un puerto seguro a este navío según
anunció la ong sos mediterráneo el nuevo
ejecutivo de ultraderecha italiano ha
decidido endurecer sus políticas
migratorias autorizando desembarcos
selectivos de personas migrantes algo
que organizaciones de defensa de los
Derechos Humanos consideran contrario al
derecho internacional humanitario en los
últimos días varios barcos humanitarios
han llegado a puertos italianos
amplificando esta problemática nuestra
corresponsal en Italia Natalia Mendoza
nos cuenta más Son días de intensa
atención en Italia después del rechazo
del gobierno italiano al desembarco de
los 234 migrantes a bordo del Ocean
baking de la ong eso es mediterráneo el
navío recibió Este martes la
autorización por parte del gobierno
francés de ingresar al puerto de
Marsella al sur de Francia según reporta
la agencia de prensa italiana ansa el
gobierno italiano manifestó su
satisfacción en un comunicado de prensa
en el cual expresó su agradecimiento por
la decisión francesa de compartir la
responsa de la emergencia migratoria que
califica como un problema europeo que no
solo concierne a los países del sur de
Europa expuestos por su situación
geográfica el barco debería estar
llegando a Marsella el próximo jueves
paralelamente otros tres barcos
humanitarios con abor de unos 800
inmigrantes han llegado en los últimos
días a varios puertos italianos todos se
han confrontado con la política anti
inmigración del nuevo gobierno italiano
de ultraderecha una ejecutivo que ha
decidido permitir únicamente en los
desembarcos selectivos autorizando pisar
Tierra Firme solamente a mujeres a
menores de edad y a pasajeros enfermos o
con necesidades humanitarias
consecuencia de esto en uno de estos
barcos el humanity 1 de La ong alemana
sos humanity 35 inmigrantes siguen
bloqueados a bordo de la embarcación
según Fuentes que se encuentran en este
bar estas personas están sufriendo un
Calvario a bordo padecen de crisis de
ansiedad depresión y han iniciado una
huelga de hambre la ong ha anunciado
acciones legales contra el gobierno
italiano ya que considera que es ilegal
no dejar desembarcar a estos inmigrantes
hasta aquí este repaso informativo pero
recuerden que a las 8 de la noche hora
de Bogotá quito Lima Pueden seguir en
directo un especial sobre las elecciones
de medio término de Estados Unidos
presentado por nuestro compañero
Santiago López con expertos y
periodistas sobre el terreno no se
quedan sin toda esta información sigan
con nosotros en France 24 y Franz 24.com
[Música]